[موسيقى]
لعل الطبيعي والذي رايناه كثيرا خاصه
مؤخرا هو حنين العرب والمسلمين لحضاره
الاندلس التي عاشت لقرون في شبه الجزيره
الايبيريه حيث شيدوا امجدا لم تزل اثارها
الى اليوم لكن غير المالوف ربما هو حنين
الاسبان لهذه الحقبه بالحوده للبحث عن
جذورهم وتعلم اللغه العربيه والغوص في
تاريخ هذه الفتره من حياه اجدادهم
واجدادنا اجدادنا الذين بنوا عاصمه بلادهم
مدريد او بالاحرى مجريت التي تعني مجرى
المياه الوفيره وما زال نظام المياه الذي
اسسه المسلمون فيها جاريا فرغم مرور اكثر
من 500 عاما على انتهاء الحكم الاسلامي في
هذا البلد فان ارثه الاندلسي غالب محاولات
الطمس ولم يزل حيا
رفعيل باحث اسباني نظر نفسه للتعريف
بتاريخ مدريد العربيه واسس مشروعا لهذا
الغرض ويعبر عن شغف متزايد لدى قطاعات من
الشعب الاسباني للبحث عن الجذور العربيه
والاسلاميه في هذا البلد يقول الباحث في
التاريخ الاسباني
ان التاثر بالهويه الاندلسيه لا متناهن في
الثقافه الاسبانيه يشير الى ان السلام
الوطني الاسباني اندلسي الاصل نستكشف
ابعاد هذا التاثر في قصتنا الاندلس الارث
الحي مع جونزاليس وايضا مع مارتينيز الذين
تجول معه للتعرف على ما بقي من اثار
اسلاميه في مدريد نلتقي ايضا الاستاذ
الجامعي دانيال خيل بني اميه للتعرف على
نبذه من التاريخ العربي لمدريد وجهود جمعه
ننتقل منها الى غرناطه اخر مدينه سقطت في
الاندلس للتعرف على نظام الري الذي اسسه
العرب فيها وفي طليطله نتعرف على الارث
المعماري الاندلسي وحرفه الفن الدمشقي
التي يتوارثها العديد من
وفي قرطبه حاضره الخلافه الاندلسيه نتعرف
على النشاط مؤسسه البيت العربي خصوصا في
تعليم اللغه العربيه للاسبان كما نعيش مع
عائله اسبانيه رحلتها في البحث عن اصولها
الاسلاميه والعوده للنطق الشهاده نستكمل
بقيه القصه مع الدكتور حسين
المستعرب والاكاديميه والاستاذ بجامعه
غرناطه والدكتور عامر ممدوح خيرو استاذ
التاريخ الاندلسي بالجامعه العراقيه مع
ضيفينا نحاول فهم ابعاد هذا الشغف في
البحث عن الجذور الاسلاميه في اسبانيا
وكيف تطور التعامل مع هذا الارث العربي
الاسلامي في اسبانيا وهل يمثل هذا الميراث
فرصه للتقارب بين الثقافتين العربيه
والغربيه لكن ما رايكم بدايه ان نشاهد
القصه وبعدها نبدا الحوار
[موسيقى]
هنا
واقوى
ونقوش واسماء وحرف وغيرها من المعالم
الاسلاميه الحاضره في حياه الاسبان اما
التوجه الشعبيا لدى قطاعات عده من المجتمع
الاسباني نحو البحث في الجذور العربيه
والاسلاميه لهذا البلد
[موسيقى]
التاثر بالهويه الاندلسيه المتناهيه
النشيد الوطني الاسباني هو من اصل اندلسي
تتبع البحث عن الاصل الاسلامي في حياه
الاسبان لا حصر له لان الارث موجود في
العديد من الجوانب الثقافيه وما زال حيا
دراسات وابحاث ومبادرات مختلفه ساعه
لاعاده الاهميه الكبيره للارث الاسلامي
والعربي الذي اسهم في مختلف مجالات
الثقافه والفن والمعرفه في اسبانيا
في هذا الفيلم نعايش نماذج من مدن اسبانيه
مختلفه يسعى مواطنها لاكتشاف الاثار
الاسلامي في اسبانيا والذي ما زال حاضرا
في حياتهم حتى يومنا هذا
سيده
الاسبانيه مدريد المدينه التي بناها العرب
واسمها
واصبحت لاحقا تنطق مدريد ينظم الباحث
الاسبانيوس جولات منتظمه للمواطنين
الاسباني
للحديث عن تاريخ مدريد العربيه يا سيدي
منذ عشر سنوات بدات في تنفيذ مشروع ثقافي
يدعى مدريد العربيه
حيث احاول تعزيز وصيانه القيمه التاريخيه
للتاريخ العربي الاسلامي في مدريد
فخلال عشر دقائق يبدا الزوار في البحث عن
الاصل العربي لاسم عذراء المدينه والبحث
عن اصل الاسم العربي لمدريد عليه
[موسيقى]
داخل مكتبه المقتضي بالوثائق والخرائط
يعكف دانيال خيل بني اميه الباحث والمنسق
العلمي لمركز الدراسات الاسلاميه في مدريد
على جمع تاريخ مدريد العربيه
هي مؤسسه كرست جهدها للدفاع عن التراث
الاسلامي في اسبانيا ومنذ اربعه او خمسه
اعوام طورت مشروعها لاستعاده مدريد
العربيه الاسلاميه لان المغرب
تاسست مدريد في منتصف القرن التاسع حوالي
عام 860 للميلاد على يد الامير القرطبي
محمد الاول وبقي تحت سيطره الاندلس لمده
225 عاما تقريبا حتى عام 2005 عندما غزاها
ملك قشتال الفونسو السادس وتم دمجها
بقشتاله لكنها احتفظت لمده 500 عام لاحقا
باقليه مسلمه مهمه
لذلك يوجد في مدريد حوالي 750 عاما يمكن
القول انها من التراث الاسلامي المخفي
[موسيقى]
بتاريخيا غزا اسبانيا الرومانو والقوط
والمسلمون ومن بين هؤلاء كان للمسلمين
الاثر الابرز في شكل الهويه الاسبانيه
[موسيقى]
حتى يومنا هذا ارتبط كل فن الضخم بالفن
الاسلامي باستثناء الكاتدرائيات القوطيه
الرئيسيه
[موسيقى]
في غرناطه وهي اخر مدينه سقطت في الاندلس
لا يقتصر الارث الاسلامي على الارث
المعماري الجميل الذي يميز الطابعه
العمرانيه لهذه المدينه بل يشمل انظمه
طورها العرب لخدمه البنيه الزراعيه
والصناعيه
في غرناطه ووفق حساباتي يوجد اكثر من 500
منطقه تستخدم شبكه كامله من انظمه قنوات
الري وهو نظام مركزي يعود الى العصر
العربي منذ اكثر من الف عام
[تصفيق]
انا هنا فيما يسمى بمطحنه وهي مطحنه دقيق
قديمه استفادت من قوه الماء القوه الدافعه
للماء لتحريك عجلاتها الدواره وطحن الحبوب
وتحويله الى الدقيق لصنع الخبز لاحقا ونحن
الى يومنا هذا نواصل الحفاظ على اليه
توزيع المياه وري حقولنا بالذات الطريقه
وبالذات اللوائح التي كانت موجوده في
العصر العربي
اطلق مصطلح الفن المدن القديم على الفن
المعماري الاسلامي الذي واصل المسلمون
بناؤه تحت الحكم القشتالي المسيحي
[موسيقى]
في حاله اسبانيا تم اختراع مصطلح الفن
المدجن القديم باعتباره تعايشا بين
العناصر المسيحيه والاسلاميه التي سمحت
لاسبانيا بعدم الاعتراف بالتاثير الاسلامي
الهائل على الثقافه المسيحيه واليهوديه
بعد فتره الاندلس او خلال وجودها
[موسيقى]
لكن في القرن التاسع عشر ومع بدء تميز
الدول الاوروبيه وعملها لابرازه هويتها
الفنيه المختلفه كان لابد لاسبانيا من ان
تقدمه هويتها الخاصه اسوه بباقي الدول
الاوروبيه ولهذه الغايه لجات الى احياء
التراث الاسلامي عبر مصطلح الفن المتجن
الجديد
بعد ثمانيه قرون من الوجود الاسلامي في
اسبانيا كان المظهر الوحيد الذي يميزها عن
باقي الدول الاوروبيه هو الفن الاسلامي
فبدات المباني المدجنه الجديده تبدو
وكانها تستعيد الفن الاسلامي لكن دون
تسميتها بالفن الاسلامي
[موسيقى]
في محطه القطار بطليطله وهي احد افضل ما
يمثل الاسلوب المدجنه الجديد الذي ظهر
نهايه القرن التاسع عشر وبدايه القرن
العشرين
بنيت محطه طليط لاما منذ 100 عام فقط
وتحديدا عام 22 بسهوله يمكن التعرف على
شكلها واسلوبها على سبيل المثال الاشخاص
الذين زاروها شبهوها بمسجد الموحدين في
المغرب او بالمباني من القرنين الثالث عشر
والرابعه عشر في اشبيليه في عهد بنو نصر
[موسيقى]
التي تحتفظ اسوارها وابنيتها بطبيعها
الاسلامي الفريد تنتشر في اسواقها منتجات
حرفه الفن الدمشقي الذي لا يزال العديد من
الاسبانيه توارثونها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مرحبا اسمي راكالدي لاتشوري امتهن حرفه
الفن الدمشقي منذ سته اعوام انا من هنا من
طليطله وحياه المهنيه مصدرها والدي الذي
ورثت عنه هذه المهنه تعتبر الحرفه
الدمشقيه مهنه قديمه جدا
تتكون من صياغه الاشكال او الرسومات عن
طريق ترسيع الخيوط او الالواح الذهبيه
والفضيه
انه لا من دواعي الفخر ان نواصل العمل في
هذه الحرفه فانطلاقا من علاقه مدينه
طوليتلا يمكن تقدير هذه الجذور العربيه
وكل ما يوحدنا مع المشرق وبالطبع نريد ان
نعمل من اجل ان يستمر الفن الدمش فهذه
الجذور تصلنا بمدينه دمشق
[موسيقى]
في قرطبه حاضره الخلافه الاندلسيه تتواصل
جهود احياء المزيد من العلوم والفنون
العربيه الاسلاميه ففي احد بيوت قرطبه
العتيقه التي يعود بناؤه الى القرن الرابع
عشر تعقد مؤسسه البيت العربي مجموعه من
الورش الحرفيه التي تهدف الى اعاده احياء
المهن والعلوم وفنون العماره التي كانت
سائده في عصر الخلافه الامويه في قرطبه
نقوم به في الاساس هو تقديم خطاب موضوعي
لمكان عليه ماضينا في الاندلس لكن مع
مقدمه علميه وموضوعيه للانتقال في هذا
السياق من عصور مختلفه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في المركز العربي تنشط ايضا دورات اللغه
العربيه التي تحظى باهتمام اسباني كبير
اين قلمك ممتاز اين قلمك و
لعبه العاب
اسباب مختلفه لرغبتك في تعلم اللغه
العربيه ويمكن ان نجد عائله باكملها في
دورات اللغه العربيه
[موسيقى]
افتحوا
هناك اهتمام رهيب باللغه والثقافه العربيه
للاطفال الاسبان تقريبا تقريبا يمثلون
نسبه
75%
[موسيقى]
يعني عندما اتكلم مع الاباء واقول لهم
مثلا لماذا تريدون ان يتعلموا اولادكم
اللغه العربيه
اللغه الفرنسيه او لغه ايطاليه يقولون لي
لا لان اللغه العربيه الان اللغه مهمه
وعندنا تاريخ مع الحضاره والثقافه العربيه
وعندهم يعني اهتمام كبير جدا بتدريس اللغه
العربيه
انا اسمي ليثيا انا عمري 13
انا اسمي كيت انا عمري اخذ عشره سنه انا
ادرس عربي في البيت العربي انا احب العربي
[موسيقى]
لغه مهمه جدا وقريبه جدا من الثقافه
واللغه الاسبانيه
المتنوعه
بعد مرور قرون عده لا تزال الاف المصطلحات
عربيه الجذور موجوده داخل المفردات
الاسبانيه ونحن نحاول اظهارها ونقلها ارنب
يستخدم الاسبان في لغتهم اليوميه نحو 4000
كلمه عربيه ككلمات اسبانيه ويسمون ابنائهم
باسماء عربيه مثل فاطمه والزهراء والمدينه
وعمر دون معرفه اصلها العربي حيث بقي
البحث عن جذور الهويه العربيه والاسلاميه
المنتشره في اسبانيا محظورا حتى انتهاء
عهد الديكتاتور الاسباني فرانكو عام
1975 الذي تلاهما يسمى بعهد الانتقال الى
الديمقراطيه والسمن الدستور الجديد عام
1978 والذي منح الحريه للاسبان بالبحث دون
خوف عن جذورهم
المدور محامي اسباني بدا رحله بحثه عن
جذور الاسلاميه مع بدايه الالفيه الجديده
[موسيقى]
ما كان يخطر بالبال قبل 21 عاما من ثمره
هذا البحث ان يولد ارشيف متحف رويث دي
المدور وهو الشيف يمكن وصفه بانه متحف
التاريخ
كرست نفسي لهذا البحث وركزت بشكل اساسي
على التحقيقات التي يمكن اجراؤها داخل هذه
العائله الكبيره
احتفظت عائله مدور بجميع صور اجدادها حيث
كان يرسم لابن اباه ويورث تلك الصور للجيل
الذي يليه ويرفقونها ببعض المعلومات خلف
تلك الصور
تبين هذه المعلومات والوثائق ان اصل
احفادهم الحاليين ليس فقط من النبلاء
الموريسكيين بل انهم من نسل السيدي يحيى
النجار الذي كان من نسل العائله المالكه
بنو نصر
النجار الى سيدي يحيى النجاره هو حفيد ملك
غرناطه يوسف الرابع الذي حكمها عام
1432 ابنه بالوما هي سليله يوسف الرابع
ومن يوسف الرابع ننتقل الى ولده ابن سيرين
الذي كان اميرا في الماريا وهو مازال طفلا
رضيعا ليست دماء المسلمه هي التي تجري في
عروقنا فقط
بعبارات واضحه اكثر لي الفخر ان اشعر بذلك
وان لدى ابنه بالوما ميولا اسلاميه وقد
تزوجت شابا مسلما من مدينه تطوان وهو صهري
[موسيقى]
لاص
ولهم دفع ابنته الى العوده لتلك الاصول
مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
كنت قد نطقت بالشهادتين منذ سنوات كان ذلك
في المسجد الكبير بغرناطه عام 2016
لطالما ملاتني حقيقه اصول المسلمه بالفخر
[موسيقى]
منكم
اعتناق الاسلام نتاج عمليه بحث استمرت
سنوات عده عندما كنت صغيره كنت استمع
لحكايه والدي حول تاريخ عائلتنا الموجود
في المتحف وعن احدى نساء العائله التي
كانت مسلمه وانتهى بها المطاف ان تعتنق
المسيحيه وهي في الاصل مسلمه وان الان في
الاتجاه المعاكس لذلك اشعر بالفخر لمعرفه
ان كل هذا التاريخ محفوظ هنا
[موسيقى]
به محاوله الوصول دائما الى اصل الاشياء
باكثر الطرق موضوعيه نقوم بذلك عن طريق
المصادر الموثقه وعلم الاثار الناس ربما
يحبون ذلك وربما لا ولكنه التاريخ لا
يمكنك تغييره او اخفائه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام مره اخرى نرحب
بكم بضيفينا الكريمين من غرناطه الدكتور
خسامي قال
المستعرب والاكاديمي الاسباني والاستاذ
بجامعه غرناطه ويصلنا ايضا ان نستخدم من
بغداد الدكتور عامر ممدوح خير هو استاذ
التاريخ الاندلسي بالجامعه العراقيه اهلا
بضيفينا الكريمين لعلنا نبدا بضيفنا دكتور
خصي ونتسائل حقيقه من الطبيعي ومن المالوف
ان اهتماما في المنطقه منا نحن كعرب
ومسلمين
بالحضاره الاندلسيه بالثمانيه قرون التي
عمرها فيها العرب والمسلمون هذه البلاد
وشبه الجزيره الايبيريه اجمالا لكن ما
راينا في قصتنا الليله هذا الاهتمام من
قبل اسبان بالثقافه الاندلسيه والحضاره
الاندلسيه والبحث حتى عن جذور عربيه
واسلاميه لدى البعض ما الذي يغذي هذا
باعتقادك دكتورخصي
مساء الخير رمضان مبارك للجميع شكرا
حقيقه توجد القصيد من الامور التي تغذي
هذا الشهور العامه في اسبانيا اتجاهلاندا
الجزء من الطريقه الاسباني الاغاني
المنتشره في الكثير من المدن والكلى
الاسبانيه
هناك كما تعلمون الكل لدينا قصر الخمره
والجميع الاموي بكور بالاضافه الى قصبه
اضافه ايضا الى المطافي
هذا من الناحيه الماديه البينه في كل
اسبانيا تقريبا من الناحيه الادبيه
والفكريه لدينا كما تعرفون
خاصه العرب حول
الماضي الثقافي الفكري
الغني جدا
والانسان
بالمشكل المكون من
اودماء
امثال خاصه
الاجيال الجديده
خاصه اعتبارا من السلاطين صنع اخيده
تقريبا
فاذا دخل الاستهداف الاسباني في الجاميات
الاسبانيه وفي المراحل العلميه
فيمكن ان نقول انه
يلاحظ باسبانيا خليه وازدهار فيما يخص
الدراسات
الاندلسيه
وبالاضافه
على مستوى مستوى شعبي اكثر
نرى ايضا اهتمام باليك
باصطياده هذه الخلايا الاندلسيه العظيمه
عندما تقول نجد اهتماما بالغ يعني ما نسبه
ذلك من الاسبان المهتمين بالموضوع هل
يقتصر الموضوع كما تفضل على الجانب
الاكاديمي ام ان هناك قطاعات شعبيه كما
اشرت يزداد اهتمامها لكن ما نسبه هؤلاء
يعني هل الموضوع فعلا اخذ في في التطور
بشكل كبير هل لاحظتم انه ربما ياخذ شكل
ظاهره ان تظل ربما محاولات على استحياء
انه في نظري في اهتمام يعني
متصيد وعميقه جدري
يعني اننا نحن نحتاج ايضا الى المزيد من
الدعم خاصه في الاعمار
السياره الاطفال
ينقصنا طبعا تعليم اللغه العربيه بشكل
منتظم في المدارس
فتوجد هناك بعض المحاولات
في هذا الاتجاه لكنها لم تكبر حتى الان
كما ينبغي
من هذه الناحيه
اقبال الدراسه اللغه العربيه وفي نظري هو
اساسي لانه عن طريق اللغه
نتعامل بطريقه جديه وموضوعيه
وممتعه
بالماضي الثقافيه الاندلسي وكذلك
اخوانينا المسلمين والعرب الجيداننا
وعندكم يعني الثقافه طبعا عالميه
[موسيقى]
ينصح التعذيب في اللغه لغه العربيه
اساسيه فنحن عندنا
يعني هذه المشكله
وهي يعني تطبيق تعليم او توزيع
دراسه اللغه العربيه هناك اقبال متزايد
وهناك طلب اذا لهذا الموضوع الاجيال
الجديده بتعلم بتعلم اللغه العربيه
ورصيدهم زادهم ربما ايضا دكتور حسين هو
انه اكثر من 4000 كلمه اسبانيه اصلها
وجذورها عربيه دعني اتحول للدكتور عامر
اريد ان الصوره من الجانب الاخر دكتور عمر
لطالما يعني وصفت في الخيال الجمعي للشعوب
العربيه والاسلاميه في منطقتنا هذه النظره
الخياليه للاندلس تلك القصور التي شهدت
تلك الزخارف تلك الثقافه تلك الموسيقى كل
ذلك الارث الجميل الذي بالمناسبه حمله
اجدادنا الذين خرجوا من شبه الجزيره
الايبيريه عند سقوط غرناطه واستوطن بلاد
المغرب العربي وحتى وصولا الى مصر لكن اود
ان اسال حقيقه عن تزايد الاهتمام خاصه لدى
شرائح الشباب دكتور خصي ايضا قال بان
الشباب اصبحوا مهتمين كثيرا بالعوده الى
هذه الجذور العربيه والاسلاميه في اسبانيا
لكن ايضا شبابنا نحن نرى ذلك جليا في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كيف تراه انت
وكيف تقراه من اي زاويه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه طيبه لك
سيدتي الكريمه ولضيفك الكريم
ابتداء الامر مرتبط بما تحتله الاندلس
حقيقه من مكانه في الذهنيه والمخيل
العربيه والاسلاميه والانسانيه على حد
سواء
الاندلس ارتبط اسمها باسم اشتهر كثيرا وهو
الفردوس المفقود وهو هذا فيه اجابه عن
سؤال حضرتك
الفردوس الاندلس بكل ما حملته من مجد ومن
انبهار حضاري وانجاز كبير جدا على مدى
ثمانيه قرون هذا الانجاز لم يكن انجازا قد
انقطع وان كان انقطعت التجربه السياسيه
ولكنه انجاز مستمر على الارض وهذا الانجاز
ارتبط به المجد الذي ضاع وبالتالي الفردوس
من جهه والمفقود من جهه فبالتالي هناك
لدينا فاجعه محو هذا التراث الاندلسي
الكبير او محاوله محو وطمس هذا التراث
اليوم الاجيال الجديده تستشعر هذا المجد
ويستفزها هذا المجد الصور التي تراها في
ما يحيط بها سواء على مستوى الاثار سواء
على مستوى القصور سواء على مستوى التراث
الذي بدا يعيد احياءه الكثير من المختصين
وحتى المهتمين على حد سواء بالتالي
الاندلس تبقى عامل جذب هذا يعني الانجذاب
الحضاري او الانجذاب الذهني لدى المخيل
العربي والاسلاميه وغيرها وحتى الانسانيه
لها ارضيه لها وجود واقعي هذا الوجود
الواقعي سيبقى مستمرا الى امد بعيد ولا
ينتهي ولن ينتهي حقيقه الامر بل على العكس
يوما بعد يوم نجد مع هذا انتشار مواقع
التواصل ومع انتشار وسائل التواصل الحديثه
نجد انه قرب هذا التراث وقرب هذه الاثار
الى كل بيت عربي او بيت مسلم وبالتالي
اصبح يعيش بينهم واوجد هذه الحاله حقيقه
من الانجذاب وهي كما اتوقعها ستكون في
تصاعد مستمر طبعا سنعود الى هذه النقطه ون
فصل فيها اكثر لكن اود ان اسمع منك ايضا
دكتور عامر الى ما ذكره ضيفنا الكريم
دكتور خصي فيما يخص الان حنين الاسبان
ايضا الى هذه الجذور العربيه والاسلاميه
كيف تقراه انت
بين في كل يعني
دكتور عفوا سامحني السؤال كان الدكتور
عامر
ساعود اليك
نعم فيما يخص الحنين الى هذا التراث نحن
لدينا اليوم متغير نوعي حقيقه الامر
الاجيال الاولى التي يعني عقبه يعني سقوط
غرناطه والسيطره على بلاد الاندلس سادتها
حقيقه قرون طويله من الغلو ومن التعصب ومن
محاوله طمس ومحو هذا التراث اليوم الاجيال
الجديده وقد تحررت كثيرا والى حد كبير من
هذه النظره السلبيه هذه الاجيال الجديده
اصبحت وهي ترى بام عينيها ليله نهار هذه
الشواخس والشواهد الاندلسيه تسمع كثيرا عن
هذه المنجزات الاندلسيه تجدها حاضره حقيقه
حتى في كما اردتم في تقريركم الجميل حتى
في مفردات اللغه هذه مفردات اللغه التي
تذكرهم ليله نهار بالتاريخ الاندلسي
التاريخ الاندلسي لا يمكن النظر اليه
بمعزل عن مسار التاريخ الاسباني وحتى
تاريخ شبه الجزيره الايبيريه بشكل عام هو
محطه لا يمكن القفز عليها تم التوهم انه
يمكن محو هذه المحطه انهائها بشكل كامل
لكن ثبتت الايام ان هذه المحطه محطه اصيله
لا يمكن تجاوزها بل على العكس ان القفز
على هذه المحطه التاريخيه والحضاريه هي
ادت الى عمليه يعني حرمان الارض هذه من
التقدم الحضاري لفتره طويله جدا دكتور اود
ان اسمع رايك في هذه النقطه
تعامل الاسباني مع هذا الارث الاندلسي
سمعت ما قاله الدكتور عامر بان هناك الان
ربما نوع من التحرر والتحلل من ذلك الارث
الثقيل ربما الذي كان في السنوات الاولى
او العقود حتى الاولى
لسقوط غرناطه
يعني اولا
[موسيقى]
نبا يعني اهتمام
من عامه الناس بطريقه تلكيه
بخصوا بالحنين ليس فقط الا
الثقافه من الناحيه
الفنيه والابديه بس خطي يعني اسماء العديد
جدا من الاماكن
كنا القصيد من العائلات كله عربي واسلامي
اصيل
وبالاضافه الى ذلك الحضور هذه الحضاره ما
في
نهار
فحتى الناس العاديين غير المثقفين
يسالون باستمرار يعتقدون لدينا باللغه
الاسبانيه حتى الكثير من الامثال كلها
ايجابيه لكل مرحله انه هذه تخفى عنها
بمعنى ان هذه اعمال او مصنوع
دقيق
فحذر من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى بين يعني
اوساط المثقفين من كبار الكتابه الاسبان
بامكاننا ان نرجع حتى ان نحضى اللحظه
الاوروبيه
كل طيار الثقافه الاسبانيه والفكره
الاسبانيه
هذه الهويه العربيه
الاندلسيه وخط الاسلاميه للماضي الاسباني
اريد ان اعرف لدي فضول يعني هؤلاء الذين
يهتموا حتى من غير الاكاديميه تقول من
عامه الناس من الاسبان يعني هل بالضروره
هم جذورهم يعني اسلاميه وعربيه ام ليس
بالضروره
ليست بالجدول من الناحيه الجينيه
يعني يعملوا مؤخرا يعني هذه النوع من
الدراسات الجينيه وتبين تبين منه سكان
شيبه الجزيره الاسبانيه مصيج من العديد من
الحضارات
بس اذا ناخذ الامور من الناحيه الجينيه
يعني ببساطه نسكت في
العنصريه يعني فهناك في يعني امور
الروحانيه اعلى واغلبيه وثقافيه
ننتمي او نقددها بطريقه
انسانيه لان الثقافه العربيه والانسانيه
ثقافه الانسانيه وشريه للكل ليمتل النصف
في العالم
حول مثل
السابقه انه خاصه مثلا طوق الحمامه
انشو هايدا عشير الاندلسيه عظيم ان لاخره
الفكر الثقافه ابن الرشد يعني كل هذا
الانتاج الهائل هو انتاج للانسانيه خالد
لا تموت
كيف يتجلى في حياه الاسبان اليوم فن
العماره نعم موجود منذ الازل وحتى ما بني
وشهد من بعد كان فيه لمسات كما تبعنا في
الفيلم وقصه الليله
احد الاساتذه الذين صدفناهم ايضا في قصتنا
الليله تحدث بان السلام الوطني الاسباني
اصله اندلسي اود ان نعرف غير ذلك كيف
يتجلى هذا التاثير الاندلسي الى يومنا في
حياه الاسبان
في كل شيء في مثلا وشباب تاع المطاعيم في
اسماء القصيد من المحلات في الموسيقى في
صحافه يعني دائما في نقاش
يفتح هذا هذا الحوار باستمرار في الوصيله
ليله ما في التلفزيونات في كل مثلا
العياده المحليه في الاديده جدا من الكثير
من
البلدات والكلى والمدن
الاسبانيه لا نزال نحتفل بوجود العرب
الاندلسيه
نريد مثلا في اجتماعات مهمه جدا في مثلا
كادير اللي فيها
المسجد
الريفي الوحيده المتبقي بالكامل باسبانيا
هويلا الى كنيسه
جمع في يعني تجمع مشكل مهن جامي مسجد وكل
شيء كنيسه سقيده
وحلبه مسارطه يعني كل ما البعض يعني هذا
وهناك اختفى كل سنه
اجتماع وخفلات ما بيسكروا
لتبادل وتقديمه المصنوعات
والاختفال
بالنوبه القديمه يعني في
وجود مستمر
كما تفضل زميلنا عمر الى هذا الموضوع
باسبانيا
بالاضافه الى الوطن العربي
لا نزال يعني نتعيش حقيقه بهذا الماضي
الحي نعم دكتور عامر يعني كنت قد تحدثت
منذ قليل عن الارث الاندلسي في بلادنا
العربيه اجداد الذين استوطنوا كما ذكرنا
بلاد المغرب العربي وحتى مصر وانت ربما
خبير في هذا الموضوع اكثر مني اريد منك
معلومات نستزيد بهوى المشاهد الكريم كيف
يتوزع هذا الارث الاندلسي ما بين العماره
ما بين الموسيقى الاندلسيه في بلاد المغرب
العربي نحكي عن الجزائر تونس المغرب كبرنا
على هذه الموسيقى الاندلسيه على البيوت
المورسكيه هناك طراز معماري معروف بهذه
الطريقه ماذا عن هذا الارث وكيف توزع في
مختلف بلاد العرب والمسلمين
نعم دون تجربه الاندلسيه تجربه عامه
وشامله بكل ما تعنيه الكلمه من معنى تجربه
حياه متكامله الهجرات الاندلسيه الى بلاد
المغرب وبلاد المشرق ويعني هي استمرت طيله
قرون عديده كما تعلمون انه سقوط الاندلس
لم ياتي حدثا مفاجئا انما هو حدثا متدرجا
وسقوط المدن الاندلسيه يعني منذ قبل قرنين
ونصف من سقوطها النهائي بدات تسقط المدن
فبدات الجاليات الاندلسيه بالهجره وكان
طبعا الظهير المغربي دوما هو الاقرب ومن
ثم الهجره ايضا الى مصر وغيرها الجاليات
الاندلسيه او الهجرات الاندلسيه التي
انتقلت الى تلك البلاد نقلت كل مظاهر
الحياه الاندلسيه بدءا من
طبيعه الحياه البناء
الثقافه حتى على مستوى الازياء والعادات
والتقاليد والطبخ
والكافه وسائل الحياه بالتالي اليوم لما
نجد في مدن مثل تطوان شفشاون مثلا مدن
اخرى في القاهره هناك بيوتات مستمره على
النمط الاندلسي هناك اثار لا تزال
نعم يعني هناك اسر عديده اصولها اندلسيه
هناك تم النقل يعني هذا هذا الانتقال
وحقيقه يعني كل من كتب عن هذا الباب يتحدث
عن يعني اذكر اذكر المؤرخ الكبير المصري
محمد عبدالله عينان واستاذنا ووالدنا
المؤرخ الدكتور عبد الرحمن علي الحجي
رحمهم الله تكلموا عن الانتقال حتى على
وجوه البشر حتى على وجوه الناس اليوم نحن
اذا استطعنا يعني جازه لنا التعبير نحن
نسخ معاصره لاجيال مندثره بالتالي اليوم
الاجيال الموجوده في بلاد المغرب في حتى
في اسبانيا اليوم في ملامحهم في اشكالهم
في تصرفاتهم في الكثير من عاداتهم التي
ربما لا يعني يعلمون مقصدها او لا يعلمون
تفسيرا لها هي انبعا هي يعني استمرار لذلك
الوجود الاندلسي بالتالي انتقاله الجاليات
الاندلسيه او الهجرات الاندلسيه نقلت
الحياه الاندلسيه ما تعنيه المعنى الكلمه
من معنى الى تلك الديار فاوجدت استمراريه
حقيقه للحاله الاندلسيه
ما اهم المجوزات باعتقادك لتلك الحضاره
الاندلسيه نتحدث عن التعليم اتحدث عن
العلوم نتحدث انتظر حتى تعيد السماعه الى
اذنك حتى اعيد طرح السؤال عليك نعم دكتور
عامر الان تسمعني نعم دكتور نعم
ما تاثير هذه الحضاره الاندلسيه في مختلف
مناحي الحياه نتحدث عن التعليم الذي كان
متطورا جدا كانت مناره تعليميه نتحدث عن
العلوم ايضا التي ازدهرت خلال ثمانيه
قرابه ثمانيه قرون نتحدث عن علوم الاداره
ايضا
والاقتصاد فبالتالي نتساءل حقيقه ما الذي
يمكن ان يكون قد استفاد منه العرب ايضا في
رحلتهم الى بلاد المغرب العربي والمشرق
العربي وحملوه من هذه الاثار
يعني الحضاره الاندلسيه هي حضاره نستطيع
ان نصفها دوما بانها حضاره ذات هويه
اسلاميه ولكنها انسانيه الاتجاه حضاره
منفتحه على الاخر قدمت ابداعا في كافه
مناحي الحياه امتازت الحضاره الاندلسيه
والمنجز الحضاري الاندلسي امتاز بالاصاله
ابتداء وامتاز بالتنوع والتعدد والابداع
الابداع على كافه مناحي الحياه وكافه
العلوم والمعارف لا سيما في العلوم
والثقافه نجد في اللغه العربيه نجد في
الادب نجد في علوم التاريخ في علوم
الفلسفه نجد على مستوى العلوم الصرفه من
علوم الطب الفيزياء الكيمياء هناك ابداع
متواصل هناك اختراعات هناك وضع للنظريات
هناك انجاز على مستوى بناء المستشفيات على
مستوى العمليات الجراحيه هناك الكثير
حقيقه من المؤلفات التي كتبت والتي للاسف
فقد العديد من عندها بعد سقوط غر ولكن ما
تبقى منها على قلته هو يعني يوحي بوجود
حضاره غنيه بانجاز كبير جدا هذا الانجاز
امتدا اثره في الاماكن التي انتقل اليها
فامتد هذا الاثر بشكل ايجابي ممتاز هذا في
رحله العوده الان دكتور فوسيه اود ان افهم
منك البعد الجغرافي شبه الجزيره الايبيريه
نعم كان تاثير الحضاره الاندلسيه
لكن اوروبيه الى اي مدى ربما تكون قد
استفادت ايضا من مختلف مناحي الحياه التي
كانت مزدهره في العلوم في السياسه في
الثقافه في العماره في غيره
طبعا باقتصاد شديد من المعروفه انه اللحظه
الاوروبيه
لم تكن
موجوده بدون ثقافه ليس فقط الثقافه
الاندلسيه بس الثقافه العربيه عامه يعني
الكثير من الكتب كتب
وكذلك من المشاركه تابعنا الفارابي من
العلماء
الا اللغه اللاتينيه
استفاد منها
العلماء
الايطاليان
يعني
بتربيه الخلق مع شارليه
مثلا في علم الطب على سبيل المثال هذا كان
من كتاب تشريح
زهراوي اللي كان من مواليد
كان ترجمته الى
يعني
مستعمله خط الكرمه
يعني في مجال علم النباتات الى اخره
العلوم الرياضيه
كذلك لدينا يعني او لا
الفوا في الرياضيات
يعني المكان ليست المكان الوحيد ولكن من
اهم الاماكن
لانتكال كل الحضاره العربيه والاسلاميه كل
العلوم
العربيه الا اللغه اللاتينيه وبعد ذلك الا
اوروبا
وازدهار النهضه يعني الخلافه
القرن 15 يعني نعم يعني هذا مهم جدا طبعا
لطريقه وفي مثلا علوم ايضا الملاحه
على سبيل المثال كان
تصنع
مهمه
دقيقه اسلوب
التبخر
الكره الجديده في امريكا يعني هذا يعني كل
الطريقه
من الحضاره العربيه والاسلاميه وعلمائها
الذين يعني يذكرون الى حد اليوم ليس فقط
في منطقتنا العربيه لكن حتى
كارث للانسانيه جمعاء كما ذكرت الدكتور
حسين دكتور حسين نريد ان نعود قليلا
للتاريخ ماذا عن العرب والمسلمين الذين
بقوا بعد سقوط الاندلس بعد سقوط غرناطه
هناك يعني نود ان نعرف بعد انتهاء حكم
المسلمين بقوا هناك ربما بعضهم رغبه
وبعضهم
رهبه كيف كان اثر هؤلاء في اسبانيا هل بقي
لهم اثر يرى انه يصعب ربما تتبع هؤلاء الى
اين وصلوا وتاثيرهم الى اليوم في اسبانيا
كما يعرفها العالم اليوم
يعني هذا يعني
يا انسانيه بكل معنى الكلمه لانه يعني
القضاء
بضربه
واحده
الضربه القاضيه
للكفيل من الظروف
الى
شعب وحضانه هل هناك تصالح الان مع هذا
الموضوع في اسبانيا هل يتم الحديث عنه
يعني بدون تابوهات ام انه لازال ربما من
المحرمات او حتى المواضيع التي يتم
تناولها بحذر شديد
يعني في اسبانيا لدينا تنكز مفارقه في ذات
هذه الناحيه لانه نحن
يعني
اراضي وخط ملكيات
لناس يعني تريد من نفس الارض يعني فهذا
طريقه الثقافه هو البحث والموضوعيه في
دراسه الطريق ربما يعني
هي
طريقه
الخلاص من هذا
الضم الذي ارتقبه
يعني
الملوك في في احد اخر هذا موجود باسبانيا
طبعا في انكاش مخطوخ من خلال خاصه
الطلب الرسميه ابناء
المعروفين والموجودين خاصه كما قال
سابقا في شمال
افريقيا في المغرب في تونس وفي بلدان اخرى
طلبوا الحكه
للحصول على الجنسيه الاسبانيه
وفي تيارات سياسيه
يعني اجتماعيه في اسبانيا تدعم هذا الفرصه
الجنسيه
على كل حال نحن يعني يمتلك الثقافه نريد
ان نشر الاخوه بين العرب بين المسلمين بين
الاسبان وبين الناس
الترابط مستمر للمستوى الشعبي من الناس
لدينا جيل مهم من المسلمين من اصول
العربيه خاصه مغربيه باسبانيا مثلا
اتفاقياتها قديمه مع الجميع
المغربيه لدينا جيل مهم جدا وحتى تشكلت
بغنابه يعني احياء جميله من السكان
المغاربه تعاقلموا والنص مبسوطين وفاخودين
بهم
نتردد في محلاتهم
يعني
يتعيشوا معنا في اسبانيا المشكله انه
اريد
لجوا بعضهم في بعض المناطق من اسبانيا خطا
بالتدريج تم تردمي من اسبانيا ولما وصلوا
الى بعض البلدان العربيه اخصوا
مضاعفه لانه هناك لما وصلوا الكثير منهم
بموجات الاخيره لم تكن تجيد اللغه مثلا
اللغه العربيه
يعني ناس ممارسه
الطقوس الدينيه الاسلاميه حتى
يختفظ
بمكتبه مدريد الوطنيه يعني
كتيب الجميل مكتوب باللغه الاسبانيه
لتعليم امور
الاسوار للمسلمين الذين نصروا
بالفعل ما يمكن ان يعمل من قبل الطرفين
للوقت وقتنا للاسف انتهى تحدث عن موضوع
اللغه العربيه وربما بذل جهود من قبل
الدول العربيه في تعليم اللغه العربيه او
على الاقل تقديم السنه في هذا الموضوع
الاسباني الراغبين في ذلك في الجانب الاخر
مع الدكتور عامر تحدثنا عن اهميه هذا
الارث الذي لا يزال حاضرا لدى شعوب
المنطقه العربيه من مشرقها الى
اقصى مغربها اشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفيه
الكريمين من غرناطه الدكتور الخسامي
المستعرب والاكاديمي الاسباني والاستاذ
بجامعه غرناطه كما اشكر جزيل الشكر من
بغداد الدكتور عامر ممدوح خيرو استاذ
التاريخ الاندلسي في الجامعه العراقيه
عدوا نلقاكم باذن الله في حلقه جديده من
برنامج القصه بقيه دمتم في رعايه الله
والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]